yeah welcome to this video playing on
five minute blitz are nice you see again
some Canadian International no freedom
master sorry obviously named after cat
stevens the musician who for very long
while now has some other name that i'm
not quite sure i can reproduce okay so
um we've got the g3 line against the
bills defense and I saw this recently
that this is a a valid option so on okay
we we are in a bit no name and frankly
I'm not quite sure that this is the
greatest setup ever for white doesn't
this look somewhat weird okay my kind of
style when I play the Benoni s2 to go
for f45 but this looks rather difficult
to achieve with the night on e 2 with a
night on on f3 this is a different story
but ok you can go g4 so g4 b5 icg 4g
phone b5 takes two eggs g4 be for me
yeah but I'm quick quick enough ok so
now before he wants to retreat and
intends to use the c-4 square I see
yeah but still let's push this knife
back to be one
h5 young now I'd like to open up the
center but i dont dont see y 6 some
happening at the moment maybe i need to
prepare the sabot night will be 6 and so
on 96 he might have a five so i play a
five myself I only hope that this is
this isn't too slow as possible
so and then then then e 6 this was my
idea on e5 I can take into d5 falls Wow
interesting very interesting but is the
cydia b3b should be tuned I could play a
pawn to c4 even a 1 1 issue of this is
always night to default to c6 in some
way but this is really a long way but b3
I can play suffice and less a reply
anyway ok my idea was to to break open
the center here and I'll do that I'm
better developed so it's um it's it's
not logical at all it's got night on b1
and yeah I thought this would be a good
reply threatening c3 killing both pieces
and at least killing the night which in
turn kills the rook so I don't know what
he replies on c4 if he takes Bishop
takes this winter at least in exchange
yeah probably even more so c3 and and
game over basically unless I blunder
pieces then then this is a winning
position it's got night on b1 at work on
a to this is funny both pieces are dead
so I play with two extra pieces
basically okay how to learn how to
continue let's take here and play a five
this is a good to do to stop things on
the King side yeah this is the sea
probably needs to do and now I basically
just need to exchange a bit of my my
material here rook to e8 and so on yeah
okay so Queen angie's have not the only
slide hope in this position okay but um
I understand that this is is a hope okay
if I take Queen d7
check
he's playing without night b1 and ruka
hua I cannot believe this must be must
be good for black I can even num
sacrifice some some material at some
point to to to kill this attack if I
need to at the ante will always need to
sacrifice at least the knight on c3 yeah
here we go cannot play without this
piece all the time may be here yet he
even has got the chance to get the FI
porn but ok I've got this somewhat
tricky King position so I didn't have a
chance to protect the c3 ponent even
prevent this the sacrifice not much I
could could do about that ok now yeah
he's playing this the Sun quite quite
well after he maneuvered himself to this
this wacky position yeah
gather the night is some covering g7
this was the IDM they want to go Quinn
to c7 to c5 if possible
you
kara want to get the Queen's off ya know
I can play Quincy five is this good
don't know yeah but at least I'm not
mated got 96 I'm coming we're done
should be shouldn't be too bad
rookie 6 i've got rooked the eight
Bishop c8 kicking me kicking me out
again okay so you need to protect e6 and
at the end try to attack her the B three
Pawn night to a five can I get a night
to 85 I actually can this way shuffle
the nights i will know i can take on c4
is this good
I can take what a form a bit on what see
for him Jack one let's let's do this low
so let's grab a for you
yeah cooking coming to g6 white resigns
yeah again that's quite ok an
interesting game of course after this
year it hit it it is a win for black I
should I shouldn't have allowed so much
counter play probably around here this
may be room for improvement this pond
coming all the way up to age 6 s it's
really a bit a bit of a pest and it
should be good for black but yeah it's a
blitz game what can you do at least I
wasn't wasn't so slow at there now ok
thanks for watching